now the main reason that Deborah
Norville is here with us this week is
because this week marks our 25th year
anchoring Inside Edition go.you her
first episode aired on March 6 1995
[Applause]
welcome to Inside Edition
I'm Deborah Norville a witness for OJ
Simpson's defense breaks her silence Wow
over the years she's covered defining
moments in our history and gone above
and beyond present critical stories
she's reported from inside of jail a
plane and a hospital but just hours
after giving birth Wow Deborah took a
short break from anchoring last year to
have surgery for thyroid cancer and like
many of her other experiences she shared
her journey with Inside Edition viewers
area where the thyroid is located
she also shared it with us she was here
at the table we're gonna talk we're
gonna get the update first but let's
celebrate you for just a second because
I think America first met you on the
Today Show it was a hello Deborah
Norville and then shortly after that it
was a girl by Deborah Norville and at
that time what did you think was going
to happen to your career because they
say revenge is really sweet yeah access
is the best revenge
success is great revenge I honestly
didn't think I'd ever be back on
television and truth be told the critics
didn't think so either I remember there
was this guy who wrote for the Chicago
Tribune at that time my career was I was
left for dead on the side of the road
you know when you read about yourself
left for dead on the side of the road
you have two choices you can either
accept their definition for what your
career is going to be or you say sir I'm
going to prove you wrong yeah and you
did do anyway so what does this feel
like you do I'm so pleased I'm so
pleased for the Inside Edition team
because look you guys know everybody
watching at home knows television is a
challenging business there's a shows
come and go and inside the Edition is
now been on the air for 32 years I've
been part of it for 25 of them the
ratings are good the ratings are great
we're growing our lead in we are the
number one show of our type out there
where the number five show in
syndication and and a lot of people
watch us so I'm just grateful to the
viewers if y'all weren't watching if we
weren't doing stories that you were
interested in I wouldn't be hearing
y'all would be talking those 25 years it
all goes by in a flash right like that
yes but can we talk about the video we
saw before
with all that hair okay so here's the
thing one of our producers has had heard
naked voice tracks of Whitney Houston
and Madonna who are phenomenal singers
but everybody's better when the guy in
the engineering booth gets hold of you
so they said let's do a short and story
and show how those people are really the
stars of the music industry if we can
make Debra sound like a rock star that
will prove it so the problem is inside
edition's sorry guys we're too cheap to
pay for anybody else's song because I
said it's a I'll sing such-and-such and
they go no you won't because we won't
pay for it I had to write this song that
you're seeing there oh you have a song
writing I get a songwriting credit and
the song is called keep on movin which
is now kind of your anthem it is my
anthem I'm gonna keep on movin gonna
keep on pushing nobody's gonna stop me
now so did you go home like that I did
so the day we shot that bit of the video
this was or baited my hair that was
maybe the most exciting thing there's a
very famous person and it's all clipped
on underneath the real stuff and we
didn't have time to take it out cuz had
three kids I get home for dinner yeah so
I walk in and the dog is at the front
door we lived in a townhouse hello it's
mommy let me in so let me in right then
fifteen year-old son was standing at the
top of the stairs he goes mom I go hey
Nick he goes he look cool my husband
said babe we're going out you mentioned
the kids let's talk about something else
we saw at the top there's a picture of
you anchoring your show hours after
giving birth
walk us through that decision not my
call you're not my call the baby came
you could have said no I'm just the girl
who can't know and my producer called me
she came two weeks early is my daughter
Makayla she came two weeks early and I
called those producer a woman at the
time said I won't be at work today but
I've got a really good excuse she called
me out 20 minutes later and she said and
she said it this fast well it wouldn't
be too much trouble do you think you'd
come downstairs so the sidewalk will do
the rest of the show I had a couple for
anything but he knows you're gone they
won't let me watch a good like you know
what note to self they are not paying
nearly as much as you were obviously
worth of these I said if it's okay with
the hospital done disturbing
buddy I will do it on one condition hair
and makeup come an hour before the
camera guy said and so as you saw there
I was introducing our newest viewer so
how are you feeling I'm looking at your
neck isn't it great yeah I mean not much
of one
I'm feeling great and thank you for
asking and thank you for letting me come
on a year a year ago to talk about but
it made a difference for a lot of people
do
I started looking I started hearing from
people and and I think the message is
this you have to be proactive about your
own health we all have these things
within hands reach go in your thing and
put in a reminder every year for the
next 20 years to check whether it's your
mammogram or your prostate your thyroid
or whatever it is that you need to have
checked put a reminder in and keep that
appointment with yourself did going
through that change your approach to
life at all that's a good question
Anthony I think I have always lived in
gratitude I write books about that kind
of stuff so it does certainly enhance
that but I think it has it's it's
prompted me to not only just grab every
day and with gusto which I think I did
anyway but to to be a more of Abedin ski
to be honest with you to be a buttinsky
about no you got to go check that out
I'm a nag your slip is showing I'll tell
you you're sucking that yeah right yeah
but if I see something on you that looks
weird yeah I'm not gonna be that person
who doesn't say anything that's how it's
changed me something that's good no
that's a very good thing Deborah Norman
thanks so much thank you isolations in
case